will crow makes his 19th start of the
season in 19 games he's 3-7 with a 5-2-3
jacob stallings doing the catching
and in the air to right and polanco back
and polanco makes a fine grab wouldn't
you know it all the attention around
gregory polanco the last 24 hours and
it's the pirates right fielder who makes
a very fine catch ball two strikes the
pitch swing and a miss struck him out
one and one on carson
that's fair down the line and carom's
off the railing out there
to tell marty won't stop at third carson
kelly's got a two out double
ground ball second and there's michael
chavis his first
attempt is successful the throw to first
and michael crowe a successful top half
the first tonight it's the d-backs debut
for 24 year old right hander umberto
mejia acquired from the marlins last
august
and showing a good slider how about that
first batter three pitches and three
strikes see you later certainly a good
start for roberto struggled on the road
in la and st louis two out of 17 on that
trip but he's back home
and he has a one out single to left
and there goes hayes again taken for a
ball
bro he's going to be off
the glove yeah he did not look up toward
third but he's there with two outs on
the stolen base
called strike three alberto mejia two
strikeouts in his first inning as a
diamondback here's christian walker
first baseman facing will crow
ground ball deep short and the jump pass
and a perfect strike
for kevin newman what a beautiful play
we're going to see that one again a
couple of times tonight and probably in
the next couple of days kevin goes back
in the hole
nice jump throw and throws an absolute
strike to colin moran hits him right in
the chest dalton varshall who's homered
in back-to-back games
makes excited about the future varshall
launches another one deep center field
it's gone
dalton varshall
his third consecutive game with a home
run and the diamondbacks strike first
go back to that colorado series a line
drive to left a high fly ball to right
and now a bullet to straight away center
field wow outstanding swing already
checks her under
and he struck him out he climbed that
ladder again at 94. and he gets his
third strike up 4-2 on cattell martay
got him
the pitch had a swing and a miss crow
takes care of him kept going off speed
and about an impressive two and he's
thus far for the right-hander
now getting his first diamondbacks
starting he puts away crow on three
pitches
swinging a miss second time he's got
gamble that's five strikeouts for mejia
hayes moves on the pitch again umberto
with his third strikeout and the inning
is sixth in the ball game
encouraging through three anyway with
crow
good pitch
i love that right there will crow just
mono amano right there here it is hit it
how about that that one at 87 is the
hardest one he's thrown all night
ground ball left side newman 360 spin a
pretty play mr smooth he makes that look
so easy right there
here's the one-on-one pitch and a
swinging hard hit ground ball fair and
up the right field line and kicks off
the side while varsho has to go and
chase it down and moran halfway to
second and we'll get in just ahead of
the throw
and he's there with a double leading off
the fourth inning yeah varshall would
have played that
karen better
that's just going to be a single
but he was very aggressive going in
charging after that ball
and to left field and jacob stallings is
going to tie the game
he's headed to second
he is going to be
cheetah
for the game tying double
how about this
we've made mejia work all night he's
danced around a little bit of trouble
but back to back doubles both of them
fastballs
this one in off the plate not a bad
pitch nice piece of hidden by jacob
stalin's pulling his hands in and
getting the barrel to go for baseball
berto mejia originally signed out of
panama by the marlins in 2013 made his
big league debut with miami last year
is swinging away sends one to right
center and it gets down all the way to
the wall
ombre mejia has a lead off double that's
his first career hit he gets a center
cut fastball and barrels it to the gap
in right center field outstanding
fair ball down the line this will give
the diamondbacks the lead mejia coming
around third
and katel martay will hold it first it's
an rbi single and it's 2-1 d-bags just
does keep it fair down that first
baseline
that's what you want with a pitcher
running at second base something that he
can just turn that corner at third and
jog home base is loaded two outs for
christian walker
walker sends one deep to right center
field
that ball is off the wall reynolds picks
it up martay is home carson kelly's home
here comes peralta he's in there
christian walker clears the bases and
it's 5-1 diamondbacks camel to lead it
off he swings in swats one to the left
center field gap this is down and
heading toward the notch
still rolling toward the wall gammel
touches second he's heading to third and
ben gamel slides in with a triple that's
how you run the bases right there and he
was off like a rocket right out of the
batter's box
that will get home a run
and it's five to two rbi number 73 for
brian reynolds yoshi sutsugo pinch
hitting for cool clark reddy the pitch
swinging a ball blasted to right toward
the top of that wall and gone
just over the wall
tsutsugo hits another one out is first
in his first at-bat here at pnc park and
his third of the year the pirates make
it five to three reynolds picked up an
rbi in the fifth inning with a ground
down
and toward right center field and that's
gonna get down and get to the wall
key brian hayes will score reynolds
heading to third and he's gonna be there
without a throw
a trip trip
triple for reynolds it's a one-run game
and he's 90 feet away
a little tapper breaking for the plate
he'll score no throw and in the dirt
marin is safe it's 5-5 right on cue with
what has frustrated lavello a routine
throw to first by cabrera is thrown in
the dirt
bomber in 12 games of 5-2-7
oh quick work of varshall
his 2-2 right there strike three call
with a sinking fastball over
wow
how about that little bit of work from
anthony bonda three batters three
strikeouts three straight walks to load
them up here it is and a swinging a
comebacker over the mound to short
slowly hit ahmed onto first to get the
out newman is in rbi bounce out for key
brian hayes the pirates take the lead
six to five here in the eighth and now
david bednar a chance to get his first
home save
strike three called one away
and the ground ball past the pitcher
newman there 360 spin
kevin newman
another great play
two outs unbelievable right there
to left field and the pirates
for the fifth time raised the jolly
roger
come back from being four runs or more
down in a game what a way to start this
home stand